MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This week, we're
talking all about machine
learning-- the hardware, making
recommendations, and how
TensorFlow Enterprise could
optimize your business.
I'm Mark, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Google Cloud offers a range
of solutions for enterprise
situations, allowing
customers to choose
what fits best for them,
even down to the chip.
Recently, Google Cloud TPUs
broke the scalability records
for inference, adding to
the previous record-breaking
success for learning.
So if cutting edge
deep learning workloads
are a core part of
our business, you'll
want to take a
look at Cloud TPUs.
It's nothing
unusual to recommend
ways to optimize your cloud
infrastructure and security
settings.
But what is unusual is how
Google Cloud uses machine
learning to power
our suggestions.
One such tool is the Cloud
Identity and Access Management
Recommender, which
we've cracked open
for a behind the scenes
look at the machine learning
that powers it.
TensorFlow is one of the
most popular machine learning
frameworks, which
was made universally
useful with the launch
of TensorFlow Enterprise.
And now, we're expanding on
the enterprise-grade support
and performance
with improvements
in reading data from Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
The speed of getting data from
Storage to the ML training
process can be critical
for AI-enabled businesses,
so we're here to optimize.
KubeCon and CloudNativeCon
2019 is happening right now,
November 18 through 21,
in San Diego, California.
If you want to learn more about
Cloud solutions of all sorts,
you should come.
Registration is still open,
and it'll be available on site.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.